-Finally, as we mentioned,
the Alabama legislature
voted yesterday
to almost entirely ban abortion
in their state.
It's the most sweeping abortion
ban seen in the U.S.
since Roe v. Wade.
Here to talk about it
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, Seth.
-Hey, Amber. What's going on?
-Well, I no longer have control
over my own body!
That's what's going on.
I want to talk about abortion,
but I have to do it like this.
-Yeah, but you don't live in
Alabama.
This law doesn't apply to you.
-No, but this is where our
country is headed.
So we figured we may as well get
some practice.
-All right. Let's talk about it.
-Alabama's new law makes it
almost impossible for a woman to
get an abortion.
You can't get one.
No one can get an abortion!
-I mean, this is really serious,
right?
-I know.
And Republicans designed the
bill to be challenged in courts
so that they can try to overturn
Roe versus Wade.
[ Laughter ]
It's a scary time to be a woman.
I'm scared.
-I bet.
-I have a question.
-Oh, yeah. Yes?
-If Alabama is going to force
women to have babies,
are they going to help them
take care of them?
-No! Alabama has no paid family
leave laws.
-What?!
-I know.
-I'm shocked!
-I know!
-Then who's going to help
care for these babies
and feed them
and rock them to sleep?
Wait. I'm sorry. You think
that's how you rock a baby?
[ Laughter ]
-I -- I don't know. I'm a man.
We don't know this kind of
stuff.
-Yeah, no [bleep]
-What does it feel like to be
a woman in America right now?
-I can tell you what it feels
like.
It feels like you're not even
a person.
Like you have been stripped
of your humanity.
That you are not valued
by the men
who were elected to serve you.
And it makes you wonder where
you'll get the strength
to fight the battles
that need fighting.
-Wow, that's really powerful,
but, um,
why are you lying on the floor?
-Oh, my guy's stuck in traffic.
[ Laughter ]
-I see.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We hear a lot about what
women are doing
to fighting anti-choice laws,
but what could men do?
-Elect women!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Great idea. Give it up
for the women of "Late Night,"
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]